i want to start today with something
that many of us at this point
intuitively probably understand and
something that's also been made explicit
by the fbi and other law enforcement
agencies over the last year or two
which is that at this point in time for
the united states without saying
anything about times past necessarily
right now
the u.s is facing
as
way more domestic terror threats as
foreign terror threats there's a very
interesting
newsweek article about this which says
the us is facing far more domestic
terror threats than those from
international parties according to the
fbi
timothy langan assistant director of the
bureau's counterterrorism division told
lawmakers wednesday that the u.s is
approaching more than 2700 domestic
terrorism threats the number of
international terror threats is under 1
000.
langan also gave statistics on
terrorism-related deaths in the u.s from
2015 to 2020 there were 80 reported
international terrorism-related deaths
compared with 83 deaths linked to
domestic terrorism
langan's testimony follows fbi director
christopher wray's statements to
congress earlier this month when he said
the number of domestic terrorism cases
has exploded in the last year and a half
a recent ap poll found more americans
are concerned about threats from
extremist groups based on based in the
u.s as opposed to those from other
countries
65 percent of u.s adults report being
extremely or very concerned about
domestic group threats compared with 50
feeling the same about foreign extremist
groups
um
we there there's a couple things here
one is it's really common
that
people's fear of things is often out of
line with the actual
danger of that thing
uh we see this with vaccine stuff right
there are lots of people who are afraid
of kovid but this movement of people
afraid of the vaccine when really it's
coveted you should be much more afraid
of that would be one example in general
people tend to worry much more about for
example being the victims of a terrorist
attack despite it being insanely
unlikely that any of us would ever be
doesn't mean some people won't be but
statistically speaking insanely unlikely
versus things we don't think much about
like getting in a car every day which is
actually um a comparatively dangerous
thing given the number of people who die
yearly from terrorism in the us versus
the number who die in car accidents or
being more afraid of flying than driving
in a car even though the driving in the
in a car
is far more dangerous okay so so that's
one thing that oftentimes even though
the domestic terror threat is a bigger
threat people think of the idea of often
it's
dangerous muslims from the middle east
or sometimes it would be brown
immigrants from latin america or
whatever the trope of the week month or
year happens to be
but then number two
you know there are entire media
apparatuses in the united states
that are very similar to what we see in
other countries
radicalized people
into what is often referred to in the
u.s as a
jihadist terror or islamic
or islamist terror
we have the equivalent in the united
states of these media outlets that
spread hate uh and so fear and
radicalize people
and
many americans don't recognize them as
being the sort of domestic equivalents
of the stuff that we say wow how do
these people these people end up getting
radicalized into isis for example and
you look at the media and the internet
content but then we wonder how did so
many people end up getting radicalized
to the point where they rioted on
january 6th or
they put pipe bombs in washington dc or
whatever the case may be
and then you look at what we have uh
happening on facebook and oan newsmax to
some degree
fox news and uh uh alex jones and so
many others this stuff radicalizes
people as well
and um
[Music]
it should come as no surprise that when
the rubber hits the road the domestic
terror is actually far more of a threat
mathematically
than the foreign terror and yet another
report from the fbi confirms exactly
that now if you think that
although the number
may be greater
it makes sense because well you're in
the u.s so the americans are already
here that doesn't mean that
they're more dangerous on average there
may be more of them and you know if it's
83 versus 80 deaths from terror the fact
that there are more threats doesn't mean
that much i would disagree the fact that
there are that many potential nodes of
radicalism and terrorism domestically
means that there's way more people who
could be activated could be activated by
the exact type of rhetoric that we've
been fighting against let me know your
thoughts
one of our sponsors is aura think about
all of your online accounts finances
your devices
how are you protecting them hacking
data breaches identity theft these are
bigger issues now than they've ever been
before
aura is a new type of security service
it protects your online data your
internet connection your devices with
one subscription you'll be alerted to
fraud and threats quickly like if your
online accounts or passwords were leaked
if someone tried to open a bank account
in your name with an easy online
dashboard an alert sent straight to your
phone aura keeps you in control and
guides you through solving any issues
all plans come with a one million dollar
identity theft insurance to help recover
stolen funds so if you want to secure
your online presence from hackers and
scammers check out aura you'll get 40
off all plans when you go to aura.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video